ja wir kommen zur ersten sitzung eines
seminares über ethik der digitalität
heute gibt es eine kurze einführung in
die thematik und ein überblick über die
themen die wir im rahmen dieses
seminares behandeln wolle zunächst mal
ethik der digitalität versus ethik der
digitalisierung bestimmt fragen sie sich
jetzt was uns eigentlich eine ethik der
digitalität ist das nicht dasselbe wie
eine ethik der digitalisierung poetik
der digitalisierung da gibt schon einige
bücher dazu die heißen dann manchmal
auch digitale ethik links das buch von
den reglern verlag kompakt wissen xl
leben in vernetzten welten findig und
sehr treffen untertitel kann ich ihnen
auch empfehlen zur einführung dieses
buch und rechts von sarah spiekermann
digitale ethik ein wertesystem für das
21 jahrhundert
das ist jetzt die digitale ethik oder
die ethik der digitalisierung was ist
jetzt der unterschied dazu zu einer
ethik der digitalität ethik der
digitalisierung oder die digitale ethik
die betrifft gemeinhin die technik
features dienst geht also um eine
technik die digitalisierung und um die
frage wie wir philosophisch mit dieser
technik umgehen können und sollen oder
auch dürfen das heißt das betrifft die
angewandte philosophie also die
philosophie dies mit konkreten
speziellen problemen zu tun hat es gibt
auch noch andere formen der angewandten
ethik es gibt tierethik zum beispiel das
ist auch eine angewandte ethik und die
eben einen bestimmten bereich auch ein
spezialfall betrifft und da versucht
eine anwendung zu finden an ethische
anwendung bei der ethik der digitalität
geht es mir jetzt ausdrücklich nicht nur
sich um eine technik philosophie und
nicht nur um eine angewandte philosophie
ich verstehe digitalität weiter oder
auch vielleicht ein bisschen umfassender
als die digitalisierung das heißt ich
verstehe digitalität im sinne einer
lebenswelt in seiner philosophie der
lebenswelt und im sinne anthologie sogar
wie ist die lehre des seins sein denn
das heißt digitalität ist insofern
weiter oder auch vielleicht noch
grundlegende als digitalisierung weil in
digitalität angezeigt wird dass die
digitalisierung nicht nur ein
angewandter bereich ist ein
spezialbereich der ein teil unserer
lebenswelt ist sondern dass digitalität
die gesamte lebenswelt von uns betrifft
das ist natürlich jetzt eine starke
these weil so ist es sicherlich noch
nicht bei uns allen aber man könnte ihr
zu these vertreten die vertretung dass
die digitalisierung als technologisches
phänomen die bedeutung hat das sie von
nichts vor keinem bereich unsere
lebenswelt halt macht das ist in meinen
augen die hauptsächliche ethische
herausforderungen der digitalisierung
digitalisierung ist ein phänomen ganz
ähnlich wie elektrifizierung des wahren
phänomen was ist 150 jahren gab es 1870
80 pariser weltausstellung da begann so
langsam alles sich zu elektrifizieren
das hat noch lange gedauert es gibt
sicherlich auch noch menschen die das
nicht wollen das ist auch völlig ok
elektrifizieren aber jeder mensch kann
es prinzipiell haben das hat sich also
rasant ausgebreitet die elektrifizierung
sie hat vor keinem lebens jeglichen
bereich eigentlich alt gemacht man kann
alles elektrifizieren fast seines lebens
nicht alles aber fast alles und die
digitalisierung geht noch einen schritt
weiter weil die digitalisierung noch
mehr digitalisieren kann als nur mit der
elektrifizierung elektrifizieren kann
ich gebe nur ein beispiel denken sie an
künstliche intelligenz man kann und da
unser denken zu einem bestimmten grad
auch digital ja was simulieren
rekonstruieren imitieren oder gar
duplizieren also ein neues denken
stoffen ist die frage jedenfalls das
geht mit elektrifizierung nicht so gut
man braucht sicherlich die
elektrifizierung um unser denken zu
digitalisieren dh
die digitalisierung setzt die
elektrifizierung voraus aber sie geht
eben darüber noch hinaus weil sie dass
es immer so ein bild in alle bereiche
eindringen kann sie ist so eine ganz
feine struktur diese 001 und mit diesen
0 und 1 1 können wir ganz verschiedene
dinge ganz verschiedene phänomene
rekonstruieren
simulieren und vielleicht sogar auch neu
generieren wie wir es eben bisher noch
nicht konnten und hier ist eben
maschinelles lernen künstliche
intelligenz im sinne des maschinellen
lernens von besonderer bedeutung das ist
nur ein fall wir sehen das künstliche
intelligenz als paradebeispiel der
digitalisierung in immer mehr bereiche
unserer lebenswelt ein trinkt wenn ich
jetzt ganz laut sagen würde ok google
dann würde hier plötzlich war es bei mir
im zimmer angehen deswegen sage es nur
ganz leise und
es wird damit nicht aufhören ki wird
immer mehr bereiche unseres lebens
durchdringen und zwar unmerklich nicht
so dass da jetzt plötzlich eine fremde
macht
mit stampfenden schritten wie ein großer
kampfroboter in unsere welt tritt das
ist sicherlich nur eine fiktion sondern
ganz unmerklich die digitalisierung oder
eben konkret die künstliche genc die
wird immer mehr teil und zwar ganz
normaler teil unserer lebenswelt damit
wird natürlich auch unsere lebenswelt
verändert in verschiedener hinsicht und
wir müssen uns als philosophin und
philosophen fragen ob diese veränderung
ethisch gut oder ethisch schlecht das
ist unsere rolle und das ist auch die
frage die diesem seminar zugrunde liegt
also kurz gesagt
these ist digitalität bedeutet die
gesamte lebenswelt also unseren gesamten
alltag die digitalisierung hat die
tendenz alles zu betreffen und eben
nicht nur einen bestimmten bereich es
ist nicht nur partiell sein sie ist cool
is tisch gewissermaßen und wenn die
digitalisierung alles betrifft das hat
auch ein bisschen was totalitäres das
muss man immer kritisch sehen dieses
ganze dann stellt sie die philosophie
vor ganz neue herausforderungen die
nicht nur
bereichs
betreff angewandte philosophie und dann
wird das zu einer wirklich
existentiellen frage also existenz
philosophie und digitalität irgend ganz
eng miteinander zusammen weil auch die
frage nach der digitalen existenz von
uns eine rolle spielt da komme ich
gleich noch genauer drauf zu sprechen
auf den beruf der digitalität und
verwandte begriffe komme ich auch in der
nächsten sitzung noch genauer zu
sprechen diesen begriff hat felix
stalder unter anderem geprägt ein
schweizer kulturwissenschaftler der von
einer kultur der digitalität spricht und
eben damit auch zeigt es ist nicht nur
eine technik eine angewandte philosophie
ist es eine kultur und kultur hat immer
da ist ansicht dass sie ganz
verschiedene bereiche betrifft also auch
diese ganzheitliche dimension der
digitalisierung anspricht ja das ist so
eine wichtige dimension ich kann dazu
sagen ich habe im letzten semester in
münchen eine vorlesung gehalten mit dem
titel philosophie der digitalität da
habe ich ganz verschiedene bereiche
dieses großen themas versucht zu
entwickeln wer sich dafür interessiert
auf youtube mache ich dann oben rechts
ein link zu dieser playlist hinein da
können sie sich alle einzelnen vorlesung
noch mal genauer ansehen ja genau so
müssen wir jetzt jede der digitalität
von der ethik der information
unterscheiden ich hatte in meiner
seminare ankündigung geschrieben dass
wir uns vor allem auf luciano flori die
diesen ganz bekannten oxforder internet
philosophen am oxford internet institute
ist der ansicht dass wir uns mit dessen
philosophie befassen und zwar mit dieser
schrift die fx auf information dieses
buch gerichts die passiert auf der
philosophie auf information wir wollen
uns vor allem auf diese ethik der
information beziehen
was ist jetzt der unterschied zwischen
eine ethik der digitalität warum spricht
flori die nicht an einer flosse die auf
digitale tier oder einen effekt auf die
detektive und spricht immer von
informationen was es jetzt also der
unterschied zwischen einer dicke
digitalität und einer ethik der
information
ja
da kann man drauf zu sprechen kommen
dass eben daten und informationen im
gegensatz stehen zu handlungen und leben
mit daten und informationen also es
verhält sich da ganz ähnlich wie mit dem
verhältnis von digitalität und
digitalisierung
daten informations sind ein eher ein
paar ziels phänomen der digitalisierung
die aber durchaus alle unsere
lebensweltlichen bereiche betreffen das
stellt luciano floridis sehr detailliert
und sehr überzeugen zwar durch eine aus
er bezieht sich wenn es um die
digitalisierung geht auf informationen
das ist ein grund begriff und er geht
soweit mal die frage zu diskutieren ob
alles das was wirklich ist auch
information l ist das was information l
ist auch wirklich ist wir kommen darauf
noch genauer zu sprechen das ist ein
satz von
tegel georg wilhelm friedrich hegel der
gesagt hat alles das was wirklich ist
vernünftig und alles das was vernünftig
ist ist wirklich
und er hat macht das anhand der
informationen
ja das ist eine spannende frage als man
kann eben auch sagen die information als
digitales phänomen also wir können diese
information auch als digitales phänomen
verstehen auch wenn nicht alle
informationen digital sind die
information sagt lori die ist ein
begriff der unsere ganze lebenswelt
betrifft vor nichts halt macht will kann
alles im sinne der information verstehen
und jetzt möchte ich dem entgegensetzen
das ist schon richtig da wird schon
gezeigt dass die digitalisierung sehr
umfassend ist und greifend ist vor
nichts halt macht aber wie sieht's denn
jetzt aus mit den handlungen dem leben
mit dateninformationen
florida scheint mir wir werden das genau
diskutieren information ohne die
handlung zu interpretieren die mit ihr
einhergehende damit möchte ich sagen
informationen ohne die handlungs aspekte
sind eigentlich ziemlich nicht das heißt
stellt die frage was machen wir mit den
informationen
man kann natürlich auch dasjenige was
wir mit informationen machen auch
wiederum als information so stehen die
information dass ich das und das gemacht
hab zb internet aber ich glaube dass
eine handlung mehr ist als nur eine
information ich glaube dass das eine
reduktion
und die digitalität wie ich sie versteht
die betrifft eben auch die handlung
konkret unsere virtuellen handlung die
wir im digitalen raum darf ich wieder so
etwas aufgemacht den raum begriff
vollziehen und was wir nicht so gut mit
dem begriff der information fassen
können das ist jetzt meine these die
müssen wir noch genauer
diskutieren also mir geht es bei der
digitalität auch immer um die handlung
um die virtuelle oder digitale handlung
die auf basis von daten informationen
stattfinden die selbst eben auch
information l verstanden werden kann
natürlich kann nicht sagen diese
handlung im digitalen raum können wir
als information verstehen aber ich
glaube nicht dass die handlung darin
aufgeht würde sagen dass es eine art
reduktionistischen ansatz unserer
handlung sowie wenn wir auch sagen
würden unsere handlungen in der
physischen welt ist nichts anderes als
bewegung von atomen das ist auch völlig
richtig oder bewegung von kleinsten
teilchen und zum gehirn am körper usw
aber da damit verstehe ich nicht
wirklich fast die handlung gedeutet und
so scheint es mir ähnlich zu sagen mit
dem verhältnis von digital behandlung
und informationen des nur kurz vorweg
also ich möchte mich auch so ein
bisschen der abgrenzen in diesem seminar
mit ihnen gemeinsam ich nehme auch gerne
andere meinung natürlich auf von einer
bloßen informationspolitik das ist
glaube ich auch nicht das ganze was die
ethiker digitalität betrifft ja jetzt
möchte ich ein paar leitfragen des
seminars ihnen vorstellen die wir
gemeinsam hier dann diskutieren wollen
also welche neuartigen ethischen
herausforderungen
gehen mit der digitalisierung einher
das ist vielleicht die hauptfrage sind
es überhaupt neuartige ethische
herausforderung ist auch eine große
frage man kann mit guten gründen auch
sagen es gibt da keinen neuen ethischen
herausforderungen die durch die
digitalisierung in die welt kommt die es
nicht schon davor war es ist nichts neu
an ethischen problemen durch die
digitalisierung entstanden können wir
darüber diskutieren ich glaube es gibt
neue probleme aber man kann auch mit
guten gründen das gegenteil gehabt
nächste frage was ist überhaupt
digitalisierung und was sind neue medien
mir kommt auch darauf an dass wir so ein
bisschen was zum hintergrund erfahren
digitalisierung digital analog diese
differenz ich glaube aber nicht dass sie
entscheidend ist für die ethik der
digitalität sie ist entscheidend für die
ethik der digitalisierung nicht für die
idee der digitalität wichtiger ist
vielmehr der begriff der neuen medien
was ist überhaupt ein medium wollen wir
uns den nächsten sitzung fragen und was
ist ein neues medium was macht das
medium neu durch die digitalisierung
dann eine ganz wichtige frage ich habe
den begriff schon kammer jetzt verwendet
ohne ihn genauer zu bestimmen was ist
virtuelle realität
und wie finden ist virtuelle realität
ethisch relevanten
denkt man virtuelle realität ist
dasselbe wie simulation der stellen sie
sich vor sie haben so eine brille auf
seine brille und dann laufen sie der in
virtuellen raum dass eine komplexe
simulation da könnens interagieren und
dann fragt man sich aber warum ist das
jetzt ethisch relevant simulationen sind
auch nur simulationen wieso sollen
simulationen ethisch relevant sein sind
doch völlig neutral liegt dessen
entspannende frage ich glaube wir können
virtuelle realität
weiter fassen als bloße simulation ich
glaube virtuelle realitäten sind nicht
nur den simulationen nicht nur spiele
oder scheinwelt infektionen sondern sie
sind wirklich realität ist und deswegen
sind sie auch ethisch welle
ja dann nächste frage die damit
zusammenhängt inwiefern können wir das
internet als einen virtuellen
handlungsraum sie kennen alle das neue
wort metaversum
das ist jetzt in aller munde des
internet 30 oder 40 oder 50 hier auch
immer wir können das als einen solchen
virtuellen handlungsraum bestimmen und
wenn es ein virtueller handlungsraum ist
wenig regeln welche ethischen regeln
sollten darin gelten ist es ein wilder
westen anything goes können wir machen
was wir wollen oder müssen wir uns auch
nach moralischen ekeln ausrichten und
was sind überhaupt virtuelle handlungen
ja wie können wir im virtuellen raum
handeln ist es nur ein mausklick wenn
ein mausklick eine virtuelle handlung
ist dann kann der doch eigentlich nichts
böses oder auch gutes mit sich bringen
ein mausklick ist doch völlig harmlos
aber wir werden sehen dass es so leicht
nicht ist dann ein persönliches
lieblingsthema von mir
dann über diese themen können sie dann
auch immer hausarbeiten oder sms
schreiben können sich jetzt schon ein
bisschen überlegen wie fällen sind
computerspiele mehr als nur simulationen
inwiefern können computerspiele ethisch
problematisch sein kann man sich ja
fragen ist doch nur ein spiel ist nicht
ernst diese sollte es jetzt ethisch gut
oder böse sein dann auch ein riesen
thema was wir hier auch nur in ein oder
zwei bis drei sitzungen diskutieren
können wie fern ist der einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz ethisch
problematisch da müssen wir uns genauer
überlegen was kann
wir befassen uns sie mit dem
maschinellen lernen eigentlich ist wie
das funktioniert und dann wie sollte mit
unseren digitalen daten umgegangen
werden
sowie digitale würde digitaler
personenschutz schutz der
personenschutzes individuellen worin
besteht unsere digitale identität unsere
digitale würde und wie fans sollen und
können wir sich schützen wer und wie
können wir das schützen ist es überhaupt
schützenswert
bogen besteht das digitale gut dass
digitale böse luciano fluidic der autor
dieses buches
informationen spricht von dem digital
will
meint dass sein boss
spannend gibt es überhaupt das digitale
gut und böse und letztens die letzte
frage inwiefern benötigen wir eine
digitale aufklärung und wie fern müssen
wir sie uns denken und konkret dann auch
durch das sind alles um mal ganz grob
die leitfrage des seminars es gibt
sicherlich noch mehr und da können sie
gerne dann noch weitere vorschläge
machen gerne dem auch im youtube video
unten diskussionen wenn sie wollen ich
nehme die gerne mit auf die fragen und
anregungen das gilt für alle sitzung ja
jetzt gehe ich ein bisschen genauer über
die auf die einzelnen sitzungen diesem
semester die erste nächste sitzung wird
dem thema
begriffliche grundlagen
gewidmet zahlen die nächste dann in der
darauf folgenden sitzung geht es um
datenschutz und privatsphäre
dann um das internet als handlungsrahmen
und grundrecht vielleicht also sollte
jeder menschen ein grundrecht haben auf
internet auf personale identität im
digitalen raum natürlich auch die würde
der identität unserer personen die getan
auf künstliche intelligenz und robotik
dass es eine einzelne sitzung trans
humanismus was das ist werde ich noch
genau erklären digitaler humanismus
computerspiele das digitale gut und böse
habe schon land und digitale aufklärung
das sind die ganzen sitzung an diesem
semester
und jetzt gehe ich mal auf die
einzelsitze mehr ein zunächst
begriffliche grundlagen in der nächsten
sitzung da wollen wir uns mit dem
unterschied von digitalität wäre so
digitalisierung befassen ich habe schon
ein bisschen was dazu gesagt
dann wollen wir den unterschied zwischen
virtualität und simulation diskutieren
habe ich auch schon ein bisschen was
gesagt ich verstehe virtualität eben
nicht im sinne einer simulation und
immer mehr forscherinnen und forscher
sehen das ähnlich das würde der neuen
realität der neuen medien nicht gerecht
weil sie eben lebens wirklich bedeutsam
sind nicht nur simulation darstellt auch
nicht nur
informationsspeicher man darf sich das
internet nicht nur vision groß
sammelsurium an informationen vorstellen
sondern es ist ein in der aktionsraum
wie interagieren durch informationen
aber wir haben dann eben dabei und
deswegen ist es nicht nur eine
simulation und infektion dann inbegriff
der information luciano floride wird
hier im zentrum steht ganz zentraler
begriff auch wenn er in meinen augen
nicht als grundbegriff eignet sondern
mein armes trifft der virtuellen
realität der angemessene grundbegriffe
eine ethik der digitalität dann nämlich
auf den neuen medien was es überhaupt
medium wie verändert sich medialität
durch die neuen medien sind neue medien
überhaupt noch medien im klassischen
sinne medium wirklich verstanden als
vermittlungsinstanz also nicht mit das
ermitteln wer ein instrument auch ich
vermittle information
ist es nur informationsvermittlung das
internet sie ahnen es schon ein wohl
nicht es ist ein handlungsraum das ist
mehr als eine informations familie
künstliche intelligenz und maschinelles
lernen auch diese begriffe müssen wir
genau erklären ich hatte schon gesagt
wir vor konzentrieren uns für
maschinelles lernen weil das eben das
phänomen der künstliche intelligenz ist
was unseren denken oder auch unserem
handeln am nächsten kommt weil wir eben
auch als menschen sehr viel lernen und
wenn künstlichen lebens lernt dann wird
sich darin schon sehr menschlich wir
müssen auch die grenzen diskutieren wie
weit künstler intelligenz gehen kann
das computerspiel werde ich diskutieren
auch da die frage ist es eine virtuelle
realität sind es nur simulation
computerspiel oder mehr sind
computerspiele nur neue medien oder auch
mehr als nur irgendwelche medien sind
das
formen behandlung sind die handlungen
inwiefern sind computerspiele und ich
haben bedeutet computerspielen zu
handeln und natürlich auch dann die
frage ist es moralisch pudel böse was da
passiert und so weiter und so fort sie
können gerne auch noch beitritt begriffe
dann einbringen grundbegriffe der
digitalisierung digitalität die wir
diskutieren können die nächste sitzung
wird dem thema datenschutz und
privatsphäre gewidmet wie fernsehen
unsere digital daten ethisch
schützenswert also stichwort google
sobald wir einen schritt ins internet
setzen
enthält nicht nur als handlungsraum zum
arbeitsplattform auf die wir schon
virtuelle schritte setzen können
sprechen metaphorisch sobald wir das tun
hinterlassen wir ja fußabdrücke
virtuelle fußabdrücke und diese
fußabdrücke sind mehr als nur physische
fußabdrücke dass ich wüsste wie groß
sind jetzt mal die schule ja das kann
ich aus einem fußabdruck ablesen ich
kann aus den fußabdruck ablesen wie
schwer ich bin mein gewicht kann man aus
einem fußabdruck unter umständen ablesen
nicht wenn ich auf nassen straßen wenn
ich mit einem nassen schuhe auf der
straße laufen dann kann ich nicht mein
gewicht dadurch kann das nicht
rekonstruiert werden wenn ich aber im
sand laufen dann schon
also haben wir schon ein paar daten ja
jetzt ist die frage sind das essentielle
daten bei den fußabdruck dem wirklichen
den physischen fußabdruck oder sind es
metadaten wir müssen auch das meta
datums bestimmend sind es nur äußerliche
daten dass das essentielle taten im
fußabdruck ist begrenzt da kann ich
nicht so viel raus sondern vielleicht
noch irgendwie mein alter vielleicht ich
weiß nicht wann wir sehen dass bei
archäologischen untersuchungen wenn man
da einen alten fußabdruck von 400.000
jahren fehlt dann kann man vielleicht
herausfinden wann dieser fußabdruck war
als er
vielleicht können die archäologen
archäologen noch mehr auslesen aber ist
ganz das internet das individuum dringen
sie nicht so viel wollte nur sagen
anders sieht es jetzt bei den virtuellen
fußabdruck im virtuellen handlungs oder
auch virtuell begegnungsraum des
internets aus da sind die daten doch
deutlich differenzierter da kann ich
doch anhand der daten weil mehr
herauslesen als nur mein gewicht meine
schubs lang da kann ich herausfinden was
mich interessiert was meine suchanfragen
war mein po abdruck fußabdruck sind
meine suchanfragen unter anderem und
meine suchanfragen die sagen sehr viel
gemein identität aus vielleicht sogar
fast alles
also man könnte sagen ich bin das ewige
im virtuellen raum nicht nur was ich tue
sondern vielleicht ja doch mehr war es
nicht suchen glaubt finde also wir
können anhand der suchanfragen extrem
viele rückschlüsse ziehen auf die person
die da im virtuellen handlungsraum
unterwegs meine fragen die ich an google
oder an wen auch immer adressieren die
machen meinen charakter aus dem gros
zahlen wenn sie alle ihre bisherigen
suchanfragen bei welcher suchmaschine
und immer auf listen würden
würden sie darüber sehr viel über sich
lernen oder auch über eine andere person
wenn sie nur die suchanfragen bequem da
können sie eigentlich alles über diese
person fast sagen
und deswegen ist der digitale fußabdruck
nicht im gleichen sinne zu verstehen
während physischer fußabdruck er ist
weit aus individueller und ethisch
relevant weil da unsere individualität
auch unsere ganze privatheit sich
deutlich macht und das wollen wir unter
umständen nicht das wider das weiß was
mich gerade geschäftig oder was nicht
suchen möchten das ist meine sind meine
dinge die betreffen meine individualität
und dann wenn das so ist das eben ein
virtueller fußabdruck weitaus geld als
um physische fußabdruck dann ist ganz
klar dass wir das und wir schützen
müssen oder irgendwie ja anonymisieren
müssen zumindest worin besteht unsere
digitale würde ja
stichwort internet
der denunziation haben denkt ist ja ein
solche phänomene bin ihr fake news
stichwort in die digitale virtuelle welt
gesendet werden es ist das eine wenn ich
irgendwie auf plakat schreibt person xy
hat das und das gemacht und es stimmt
nicht person xy liegt das auf den
autobahnen plakatkleber gefahren autos
durch die fahrerinnen und fahrer lesen
das und die vergessens wieder ich kann
natürlich auch flugblätter auslegen dass
dann schon was anderes ich kann es auch
in der zeitung drucken vielleicht klappt
es ja dass jemand das abdrucken
das geht aber es ist noch was ganz
anderes wenn so eine ein fake news viral
geht im virtuellen raum warum weil es
eine ganz andere dynamik der verbreitung
warum weil informationen internet wie
luciano für
reibungslos verlaufen also die müssen
nicht von einem ort an anderen gebracht
werden ja wie es bei physischen medien
der fall ist mit zeitung muss
ausgetragen werden
digitale daten die pleiten im virtuellen
raum ganz reibungslos dahin und sie
können unendlich schnell unendlich oft
vervielfältigt werden cocktails
und zwar im sinne von eins zu eins der
buchdruck hat das schon ein bisschen
ermöglicht so was die eins zu eins
kopiert
aber er hatte eben noch die physische
reibung die raum zeitliche reihung zeit
gedauert und es braucht ein material das
medium auf das leben dann mit diesen
beweglichen lettern dieses diffamierende
zurück nist oder was auch immer eben
gedruckt wurde und das ist im internet
ganz anders also das internet als neues
medium ist auch ein die firma
informationsraum ein raum des
unmoralischen der ganz anderen logen
gehorcht und deswegen ist dieses
internet im sinne der falschinformation
auch ein großes ethisches problem
ja unsere digitale identität darauf
gelegt schon eingegangen
stichwort suchanfragen also wir könnten
die these vertreten ich bin das was ich
suche und damit wäre schon viel gesagt
ich glaube es ist noch mehr besuchen ja
immer auch eine handlung nicht suchen
ist ja nicht nur eine bloße aktivität
eine bloße technische einstellung
sondern wer sucht behandelt im
virtuellen raum das heißt wir müssen
hier noch mehr auf die handlung wird ein
traum fokussieren anhand deren sich
unsere identität auch manifestiert
was überhaupt auch ein virtuelles oder
digitales subjekt das ist auch nicht
frage was ist das
also diese fragen geht es um ganz
zentral in diesen sitzungen dann das
internet lohnt sich in meinen augen als
eigenes thema einer eigenen sitzung
behandelt zu werden gerade vor dem
hintergrund dieser neuen entwicklung des
metaversum
wieder die frage inwiefern ist das
internet ein virtueller handlungsraum
ist es nur ein informationsforum ich
glaube nicht ja und dann die mich auch
immer mehr bewegende frage inwiefern
oder wie verändert sich der virtuelle
handlungsraum durch unser virtuelles
handeln meine these ist dass
sich der virtuelle handlungsraum des
internets durch unsere handlung selbst
verändert
der physische raum ändert sich nicht
durch unser verhalten vielleicht nur
ganz begrenzt
eigentlich nicht ich bin der meinung der
virtuelle handlings schon je nachdem wie
wir im internet interagieren ob wir feld
news streuen ob wir uns im dark net
befinden auch noch ein wichtiges thema
je nachdem wie wir darin interagieren
und vernetzungen herstellen so ändert
sich auch der raum das heißt der raumes
direkt oder mittelbar zumindest
gekoppelt an unser handeln und es
scheint mir was spezielles design das
internet was nicht eine entsprechung im
physischen raum hat
inwiefern sollten wir ein grundrecht auf
internet haben das internet ist ja nicht
nur im informationsraum zum internet
ermöglicht ganz verschiedene dinge durch
die informationen die ich zumeist
kostenlos frei und unmittelbar beziehen
kann kann ich lernen ich kann
medizinisches wissen generieren ich kann
es fallen
gleichberechtigte media für demokratisch
auf die ganze welt verteilen ohne
unterschiede zwischen geschlecht
herkunft alter nationalität usw es hat
also was ganz stark egalitäre das
internet und das führt in meinen augen
dazu dass man ist als ein grundrecht
diskutieren sollte so wie fließend
wasser strom freie meinungsäußerung das
internet ist der raum der freien
meinungsäußerung es ist eigentlich ein
raum der freiheit kurz gesagt und
deswegen glaube ich mit jeder mensch ein
recht auf freiheit haben sollte frei
selbst bestimmen sollte er auch ein
recht auf das internet haben das ist
zumindest meine these ist eine
politische thesen die können wir ja auch
diskutieren ja worin bestehen die
ethischen probleme des metaversum
es gab hier schon einige vorfälle bei
facebook also in diesem neuen spiel das
es dort gibt auch einen virtuellen
handlungen müssen wir diskutieren so was
wie belästigung virtuelle belästigung
das wissen fall den es kürzlich gab das
werden wir auch diskutieren
personale identität im digitalen raum
auch ein riesenthema ich bin schon ein
bisschen darauf eingegangen worin
besteht unsere personale identität im
digitalen virtuellen raum
habe ich auch schon gesagt wie viel
konzentrieren wir unsere persönlichkeit
durch suchanfragen ja in welcher form
können wir im digitalen raum existieren
es gibt eine ethik der anonymität und
pseudo novität wir können unsere
identität verschleiern das können wir
natürlich auch im physischen raum wir
können uns maske aufsetzen wir können
und wir können uns anders kleiden jike
wir haben auch im physischen raum
möglichkeiten uns zu tarnen oder uns zu
ja auch andere zu täuschen unsere
identität natürlich geht es im
virtuellen raum noch vielleicht
und so stellt sich die frage wie wir im
digitalen raum edlich existieren sollte
was moralisch in ordnung ist was nicht
in ordnung ist
sicherlich kann es sinnvoll sein zum
schutz der eigenen identität im
virtuellen handlungsraum des internets
anonym oder auch pseudonym zu existieren
oder auch im sinne von verschiedenen
rollen oder agnes ja jeder von ihnen hat
verschiedene benutzer konnten auch das
sind gewisse identität wenn man so
möchte lernt also diese frage auch nach
lokaler identität im internet die dann
doch immer noch wieder eine einheit
unserer physischen identität vielleicht
hat die müssen uns fragt die
verschiedene rollen die wir im internet
an dem können vielleicht auch sollen
oder auch nicht sollten und dann auch in
diesem sinne spannend die frage nach der
bedeutung von digitalen avataren das ist
noch mal was ganz spezielles wenn ihr
also auch noch dieses moment der fiktion
mit einbeziehen also da spielt das
computerspiel eine große rolle und
deswegen ist es für mich auch essenziell
dass computerspiele im rahmen eine
etikette vitalität zu diskutieren ein
paar tage sind ganz komplexe formen
unsere identität die auch mit
funktionalität also mit mit wunschdenken
oder mit ja mit
fantasie und mit freiheit natürlich auch
wieder mit kreativität zusammenhängt
hier können wir so sein wie wir
vielleicht sonst nicht sind und das
müssen wir ganz detailliert diskutieren
ist es nur eine fiktion oder steckt da
mehr dahinter weil mit dem avatar kann
ich ja tatsächlich etwas tun
ich spiele eine rolle aber darin tue ich
auch was im computerspiel und das
computerspiel wird eben immer mehr durch
das internet zu einem vernetzten
globalen phänomen so dass es nicht mehr
nur sowas ist dass ich jetzt gegen den
computergegner
antreten und drehte eben auch gegen
menschliche gegner oder menschliche
avatare an das heißt das ganze wird
dynamisiert durch das internet
dann hatte ich auch schon gesagt
künstliche intelligenz und robotik ein
riesenfass darüber habe ich im letzten
semester ein seminar gegeben da mache
ich auch oben rechts und links zu dieser
playlisten kooperation mit der eth
zürich
ein ganzes semester übergeben also
inwiefern
differieren künstliche intelligenz mit
unseren handlungen stichwort
mensch-maschine-interaktion also wie ich
was man wechselverhältnis herrscht
zwischen mir und der künstliche
intelligenz ist dieses verhältnis zu
bestimmen ist künstliche intelligenz nur
so ein objekt oder instrument eine
technik oder ist es nicht doch mehr was
noch nahtlos hat uns vom alltag
integriert wird uns gegeben werden ich
bin dieser meinung dass wir künstliche
intelligenz nicht nur als eine maschine
verstehen sollten wie so ein objekt was
wir in der hand haben zur vergebung
ständigen soll könnten die ganzen
prozess der eben überall anschlussfähig
ist immer mehr anschlussfähig wird an
bereits bestehende lebensweltliche
prozess und zu denken und zu handeln
unser fühlen kann dadurch erweitert
werden durch künstliche intelligenz
liefern können wir könnten intelligenz
in unsere lebens will dann auch ethisch
integrieren wo es in grenzen inwiefern
sind wieder subjekte inwiefern sind wir
objekte von ki die frage natürlich auch
um getreten wie finden eskalieren
subjektiven sein objekt ich glaube wer
dennoch ist es ein prozess
der mit uns auch immer mehr verfliest
fliesen übergang etabliert aber auch
inwiefern sind wir gegenüber der cani
subjekt oder objekte das heißt tritt
wieder die frage nach daten ethik
sollten wir menschen nur
datenbasen darstellen für die ki die auf
uns dann operiert das wäre sicherlich
auch an den vergeben stände jungs ein
gutes die ethisch problematisch ist
liefern kann keine für uns zu einem
ethischen problem werden das führt jetzt
schon richtung transform annis muss
werde ich auch noch eine eigene sitzung
gleich dazu ankündigen also inwiefern
kann kann sich so stark entwickeln dass
sie uns ja als eine gefahr entgegentritt
ob dass arbeitsplätze verloren gehen usw
das hatte ich schon erwähnt
rationalismus alter als problem oder
auch als chance wenn man sie ganz stark
sieht inwiefern verändert die
digitalisierung am ende den menschen uns
können und sollen wir durch die
digitalisierung sun über mensch werde
die position des transportministers ray
kurzweil ist sie eine prominente stimme
bei der aktuelle stimme von dem lesenden
auch ein text die vertritt die
auffassung dass die digitalisierung die
technik ganz allgemein dass die zur
verbesserung des menschen führt und dass
wir am ende eben sogar in einem
evolutionären prozess selbst zu
erweiterten technischen phänomenen
werden weil wir unser ding und sie
gehirn digitalisieren können im sinne
einer software und unser gehirn dann
irgendwann völlig nur also unsere
unserer identität letztendlich unkel um
völlig abgelöst von unserer
physikalischen basis wurden sind gering
ist also wir sind dann nur noch software
die auf neue hardware abgeleitet werden
kann das ist so seine these dadurch ist
natürlich auch der gedanke und
sterblichkeit damit der digitalen
technik einhergeht verbunden werden wir
durch die digitalisierung automatisch zu
besseren menschen ich glaube nicht
können wir durch die digitalisierung
unsterblich werden auch mit riesen
utopie die es sicherlich anknüpft an
bereits bestehende utopien aber die
durch die digitalisierung doch noch mal
deutlich dynamisiert wird auch die frage
nach unsere digitalen endlichkeit
mal voraus gedacht was ändert sich durch
die digitalisierung wenn man auch ein
blick in die zukunft wagen stichwort
auch singularität dass ein stichwort von
ray kurzweil also eine situation in der
der technische fortschritt so groß ist
das was ganz neues energie hat ganz
plötzlich auftrag wie zum beispiel
künstliche intelligenz die
bewusstsein hat das selbstbewusstsein
dazu wasser damit das müssen wir
kritisch hinterfragen dagegen hat jetzt
julian nida-rümelin ein münchner
philosoph die position des digitalen
humanismus gesetzt wie können wir die
technische entwicklung der
digitalisierung an ethische
humanistische werte zurück bin das ist
ganz stark gegen den transport ist und
das gewinnen also inwiefern können wir
einen digitalen organismus philosophisch
entwickeln wie viel können wir den
transformers muss die position die ich
im vorjahr hätten kurz beschrieben habe
mit guten gründen kritisieren
philosophisch das ist eine frage dank
computerspiele ganz neues also neu ist
es noch gar nicht was an computerspielen
neues ist in meinen augen die generelle
verbreitung und der besseren ruf der
computerspiele haben auch durch die
neuere technische entwicklung
computerspiel kann man sich immer noch
vorstellen als
aktivität von merz die welt fremd in
ihrer kleinen stickigen kammer hocken
und sich nie an die frische luft begeben
das ist sicherlich ein vorurteil ich
will nicht sagen dass computerspielen
auch so noch betrieben werden kann aber
ich glaube es wird dieser ganz großen
kulturellen vielfalt des computerspiels
eben nicht mehr gerecht oder denken sie
an spielhallen und spielcasinos häufig
denken wir an sowas oder man sucht ja
digitale demenz und so weiter sofort
darauf gehe ich auch eine auf die neuen
medien kritik sicherlich ist es ein
problem ein ethisches problem des
computerspiels aber es macht neben
computerspielen nicht ganz aus also
inwiefern sind computerspiele mehr als
bloße spielerei
weil warum soll ich mich in der
philosophie mit losen neben sichtlichen
spielereien befassen muss ich doch nicht
nur sofort sommer mit ernsten dingen zu
tun ich glaube eben schon das
computerspielen etwas ernstes ist weil
computer zu spielen bedeutet eine
handlung zu vollziehen hier wird es
wieder so spannend was ist das für eine
handlung die wir im computerspiel
vollziehen da fallen dann wieder themen
ein wie unsere identität aber tage usw
das hängt mit ganz verschiedenen anderen
themen zusammen die hier im
computerspiel besonders eng aufeinander
treffen inwiefern ist computerspielen
ethisch relevant warum sollte ein bloßes
spielerisch relevant sein ist doch
völlig egal dann eben nicht wenn ich zum
beispiel auch gegen andere menschen
antrete wenn darin auch ethisch gehalte
thematisiert werden stichwort
killerspiele und so weiter
dann das digitale gut und böse worin
besteht das digitale böse luciano flori
die hatte ich schon gesagt spricht von
einem auto fischer ii will von einem
künstlich bösen
mehr für trotz also programmierte bots
die dann im internet ihr unwesen treiben
auch spam und so weiter und so fort
wir sehen wir lassen da was los wenn wir
das programmieren was wir gar nicht mehr
unsere kontrolle haben das entwickelt
der eigendynamik wer meint dass auch
solche bots als böse gekennzeichnet
werden können stellt natürlich immer die
frage sind trotz zurechenbar haben eine
verantwortung oder hat nicht der
diejenigen die verantwortung derer die
diese trotz programmiert hat
frage auch sowie digitale täuschung
digitale handlungen die unmoralisch sind
in virtuellen raum muss man diskutieren
stichwort darknet
stichwort dieb fake warum also wenn wir
mittels künstlicher intelligenz
täuschend echte
täuschungen eben fabrizieren die wir
wirklich gar nicht mehr von der realität
unterscheiden können weil ja soviele
künstlich intelligente leistungen
eingegangen sind die ja uns einfach eine
perfekte illusion vorgaukeln und mit
wirklich nicht mehr zwischen schein und
sein zwischen täuschungen realität
unterscheiden können und dass wir dann
ethisch problematisch wenn er sich eben
gegen bestimmte personen richtet wenn
wir zum beispiel
videos von personen erstellen bewegte
bilder wo wir diesen personen bestimmte
dinge in den mund legen und wir es als
täuschend echte von bastian als die
familien das medium internet kursieren
lassen reibungslos ich hatte schon davon
gesprochen auch vom feld muss das wird
natürlich noch viel
intensivierter wenn wir es mit
künstliche intelligenz zu tun haben
kommerzialisierung ist für mich auch ein
ethisches problem als wenn das internet
als handlungsraum nur kommerziell
interessiert ist wenn alles was ich dort
tue prinzipiell zu geld sich machen
lässt
stichwort google
muss man ganz klar benennen stichwort
zensur stichwort internet beschränkung
solche dinge auch anonymität ist zu
welchem grad soll und darf ich anonym im
internet existieren bis zu welchem grad
muss ich auch virtuell gesicht zeigen ja
worin besteht das digitale gute auf der
anderen seite hier habe ich ein paar
kandidaten damals bestimmt noch mehr ob
man überhaupt gut nennen sollte ist die
andere frage open source freeware freies
internet
weiter spinnen des internets
dienstleistungen die man zur verfügung
stellt auch so etwas wie ordnung im
internet vielleicht ob wikipedia frei
informations verfügung
grundlagen schaffen für freie
meinungsäusserung
handlungsräume öffnen virtuelle nur ein
paar kandidaten und dann die letzte
frage das letzte große thema auch ein
riesen thema digitale aufklärung also
was ist digitale auf der überhaupt wenn
wir uns zum beispiel an kant orientieren
die man erkannt hat fertig frage
gestellt was ist aufklärung wir können
eben nach kant auf fragen was ist
digitale aufklärung gibt es eine
digitale aufklärung für das 21 und
vielleicht sogar schon 22 900 wenn wir
mal dass metaversum konsequent weiter
denken dann hat immanuel kant in seinem
aufsatz den werden wir in teilen lesen
was ist auf von einer
selbstverschuldeten unmündigkeit
gesprochen also wir sind selbst schuld
dass wir eine aufklärung bedürfen und
jetzt können wir uns fragen was ist denn
eine digitale digitale
selbstverschuldete unmündigkeit
wie können wir durch das digitale
unmündig werden da haben sie bestimmt
ideen ich gebe ein paar beispiele bloßer
medienkonsums wenn wir eben große
konsumentinnen und konsumenten dieser
neuen medien werden dann sind wir
sicherlich da ein ungünstig weil wir
alles für bare münze nehmen was uns in
den medien präsentiert wird auch fake
news und so weiter und durchquert das
ganze weiter dynamisiert ja dann ist die
frage nach einem digitalen ausgang aus
der digitalen selbstverschuldeten
unmündigkeit also können wir mittels der
neuen medien auch aus diesem durch die
neuen medien selbstverschuldete
unmündigkeit herausfinden oder geht das
gar nicht mehr im medium der digitalität
und auch eine frage die vielleicht
wirklich diskutieren es wert ist es die
nach dem digitalen tugenden und
medienkompetenz medienkompetenz jetzt
nicht verstanden nur als war ja
als umgang mit neuen medien bezogen auf
zeitumfang also nur drei stunden pro tag
vor dem monitor sitzen das ist
sicherlich ein teil einer
medienkompetenz macht auch bei weitem
nicht die ganze medienkompetenz aus also
hier wirklich medienkompetenz verstanden
uns in einer digital tugend wie kann ich
ein gesundes mittelmaß
etablieren im umgang mit digitalen
medien nicht nur die nutzungsdauer sind
auch die nutzungs weiß wie ich eben
selbst damit handele wider der handlungs
aspekt ist ganz wichtig also das sind
ganz wichtige frage
und zum schluss noch die frage eben
hängt auch mit der aufklärung zusammen
didaktik der digitalität um digitale
bildung also aufklärung appelliert immer
an den bildungsbegriff und dann die
frage wie können wir die bildung
bekommen wir uns bilden durch digitale
medien
also zum beispiel eine these wäre
computer zu spielen bedeutet selbst auch
an einem bildungsprozess teilzunehmen
war ein friedrich schiller wie sie
vielleicht wissen gesagt haben der
mensch ist nur da ganz mensch wo er
spielt
schiller hatte von einer ästhetischen
erziehung gesprochen können wir nicht
auch die ästhetische erziehung
verstehen im sinne von computerspielen
das ist eine frage die ich ganz am ende
auch noch gerne diskutieren würden ja
dann bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
und bin gespannt auf die diskussion